hello everyone welcome to the Halloween
edition of the need to know to show that
walks you through all the most important
things you need to know from this week's
nerdy News obviously the most important
thing you need to know is that stranger
things season two has arrived and to
know is it any good does it live up to
the hype to have a spoiler free review
with some deeper takeaways coming up in
just a second if you're impatient go
ahead and skip jump to this time they'll
flip down here to get right to it
but also just letting you know that
later in the show we're gonna fill you
and also on other things that you need
to know about this week regarding Star
Wars last Jedi Walking Dead Season
Premiere Wonder Woman stuff there's a
desk for Deathstroke movie venom stuff
yeah it's all based on the requests that
you guys send in via the starter SAP
click the start us download link in the
description down below or you can upload
your questions and your reactions to
your favorite movies and TV shows and
then you can get them featured on this
freaking show Wow
also you might have noticed the thing
that I haven't been acknowledging we're
all wearing our favorite Halloween
costumes these are our favorites yeah
that's because we're hosting a costume
contest so we've been hosting all week
at the end of this show we're gonna
announce the winners of our new
rockstars costume contest the top three
are excellent and I can't wait for you
all to see them hey Philip are you the
kind of person that when anything is a
competition you just have to go a little
bit too fuzzy I promise you I did this
in like ten minutes
don't can Devon see eight hours we had
to like attack men for power in the
stars
yeah so yeah I'm Phil Molina Eric Voss
is taking a well-earned day at spa or he
might be at the Austin Film Fest one of
those things but also filling in the
rest of the panel today are Sam basher
Oh Maude Garrett mother of dragons to
you thank you also the mother of dragons
Sam was just Sam hello and then you
might have seen this person floating
over hutch outside your house or other
shows like this this is mr. Tommy
Bechtel no you're the same guy yeah I
promise I'm a cuz it looks like you're
hiding out from a magnum p.i
let's go ahead and get started let's
start with our top story for all of you
guys to weigh in on stranger things see
you to uh to get the ball rolling here's
a little bit of a review from one of our
viewers bikal c-137 get that reference
and he brings up a very interesting
point that's finished watching episode 1
of stranger things season 2 and it's
brilliant great visuals it doesn't reset
the story like characters have some sort
of PTSD like Joyce Byers reacting to the
phone in that way I think this is pretty
good first episode bring me back into
the series after sitting there for ages
refreshing the page
Wow hot damn can't agree more alright
that raised a very good point because
the season is not just about repeating
what happened last season kind of like
I've been gushing about Blade Runner
2049 is exceptional because it asks what
are the logical consequences of the
original story and what would happen
next in that world
that's what strangers think season 2 is
doing so is it good obviously yeah it's
sitting at 93 percent on Rotten Tomatoes
but let's get into why with a panel what
do you all think oh well if I may kick
it off I loved it I've seen the first
episode and on everything about the show
so far I forgot I think the main thing
that got me into the show is the is the
music I am totally a fan of it thus far
and I can't wait but know that the show
also improves upon a lot of the show
like you had mentioned that like it kind
of builds upon it in the world
especially with Dustin Lucas because
they got silent a little bit especially
yeah last season Dustin I mean he was
adorable but that's it maybe in the
final episode he kind of brings
everybody together but you know I'm
excited to see what they do especially
with you know introduction of new
characters as well and especially
dealing with other side character barb
that is a missing person we need to deal
with that and it's going to be a big
part of the season thank God and there's
like there's logic to the government you
secret court like organization that's in
this small town like we're actually
exploring that there's a lot of really
you mean they're like exactly and that
like people are paying attention this
isn't just happening a little bottle
between these one in this little family
it's like no this has is like whole
world at least earliest Hawkins
repercussions so excited for a future
episode yes sir so they've been
listening to the audience because that's
a good thing about Netflix is that when
it comes out in a burst you get
immediate feedback and then you can
straightaway start writing and using
what you're hearing from season two for
me I like stranger things because of the
80s nostalgia that was always a big play
for me and having liked it even having
kid protagonists in a group like that is
reminiscent of the Goonies is you know
it's the Sandlot all the kids that we
grew up on having that kid vibe while
putting a lot of pop-culture references
in it and just going a sweet sweet trip
down nostalgia Lane but what I like
about season two is that they're not
making it the big focal point it's not
yeah it's not all about being stuck in
the 80s and zing-zing how cool is this
know the cover if I'm saying this but
Riverdale is really getting stuck into
that big time where they have to make a
pop-culture reference like twice a
phantom but in this one it's kind of
like it's the de corps it's they build
the environment so well but it's not
something that they're sticklers about
like for example if you just had David
Harbor and Winona Ryder a scene together
you wouldn't be able to say that it's
taken from an 80s movie that's what I
noticed anyway maybe Wynonna's getting a
little bit Precious about her here who
knows but the last season as well was
all about playing Dungeons & Dragons and
how you know the key enemy or monster in
the game was actually in real life this
one it's we know that it has something
to do with an arcade or was it just the
fact that they were in an arcade we're
not entirely sure they're just kind of
like hearing their little parts not the
focal you know when you bring up the
arcade owing to think what it is is they
live in the 80s yeah not necessarily
making references they just happen to
live in the 80s yeah instead of you know
feeling like a wink to the audience
every single time
it's just the world they live in yeah a
lot of people are would have thought
that the Paul Rizer and the sean astin
casting we're just gonna be references
in fact we even in our breakdown we we
didn't know how much Sean Astin was
gonna be in the show like it looks like
one shot based on the trailer so it's
like oh is this stunt casting and it
turns out like no this isn't just a
reference to aliens and Goonies or
whatever these people are being
officially added to that world it's not
just a reference you're Rudy I think all
of the introduction of the new
characters so far has been handled
really well I think like Paul Reiser I'm
not mad about Paul Reiser being added
and I don't mind even the best
properties associated with Sean Astin
and Paul Reiser mad about you and then
Brett Gelman is playing detective he's
great and then even the kids the new new
kid characters are kind of in that same
like they they're believably plugged in
instead of just like oh they're adding
it at an 80s trope character base they
fit into that world and they match the
tone of the already existing
performances so well yeah I'll challenge
you on I don't know they're all the most
perfect fits cuz Billy is straight out
of an 80s karate movie yeah nobody named
Billy any real they're just named Billy
in movies my name is Theodore I think
that Billy like we don't know that they
they don't give you a lot about him
except for like they kind of emotionally
manipulate you how to feel about it yeah
so far without spoiling anything yeah
he's gonna rock me like a hurricane
nothing every Wango Tango splaying when
he's driving his car which is kind of
areas I agree he's very stereotypical in
that way but like I don't have any idea
about this character I mean in the two
I'm two episodes in where are their
parents right yeah and what happened why
are they from palpable
yeah but like in the way they handled a
bully in the first season with Ben
Schwartz jr. yeah it actually took a
turn it was super interesting so I'm
excited for the Red Ranger getting his
yes he's a Red Ranger by the way it was
like oh you got out yeah as far as I
know you can correct me in the comments
from pretty sure that's who that is
literally my people ask these people
real thing so again this is we're trying
to stay as spoiler-free as we can right
now with this because I know a lot of
you guys are so benching but so not to
get ahead of where anyone is
but just as you're watching maybe
realize that there's an interesting
thing going on with the structure of the
whole season it's from what I can tell
it's structured like a movie and I know
that it's not the most original thing to
say but they actually divided this these
episodes up into it so it's nine
episodes and then three three and three
and you don't tend to get a really
perfectly third split up like that so
you get 3x which a three-act structure
is the one that we really respond to
with her heroes normally TV shows tend
to have this weird number 15 episode
wall that divides by 3 point is that
they're taking a lot of cues from movies
and the biggest most obvious one which I
think they're nailing is a good sequel
movie is their inspiration that's why it
says the big two at the beginning we're
like they're like this is a sequel tourm
hit movie from last year and they're
doing the thing that makes kind of in my
opinion sequels worth making which is
they're going bigger exactly that's
they're following it further right yeah
you have to go otherwise you're just
remaking you're just doing Evil Dead 2
just a remake of Evil Dead 1 Terminator
2 is the better so yeah yeah better than
the first one
aliens all people did buy the first one
but also specifically some they do is
they they take the story in a new
direction but based on the events from
the
and that's what's happening at the
seasons I'm super excited look where the
h2 has gone I mean better in bearing
space yeah they're in space so it's not
only love first there are some people
online they're saying that there is
liars I love it
they just haven't come out yet a
stranger things fans but the one thing
that I do kind of I'm interested in I
kind of see what they're saying is the
fact that last season started with a
nice strong hook right at the end of
that first episode with will being taken
and I was a strong and the scientist
getting attacked it right at the
beginning so this season of the first
episode I feel like you go to the second
episode a little bit more because you
like it's stranger things because it's
like the mystery yeah what I did like
about this though to come back at you is
for the first I can't look at you but
for in the first season here we could
say I'm don't look over here in the
first season and we stumble upon 11 and
we know that she was in a facility where
she was tested on and the thing is it's
like of course if she's a numbered 11
there must be others and straight off
the back out cold-open was that we met
eight spoiler but not really though but
that's like and that's going to set up a
lot more because if there's a there's
gotta be other numbers and then
multiples of three what that means and I
love when you guys ask us hey what does
it mean when I saw this it's like what
does her
DOB tattoo mean zero zero eight all
right all right so we're gonna move on
but we are gonna do so much more
stranger things content coming soon but
there's just so much more to tell you
that you need to know this week right
before we get into the other big news
stories though we always like to do this
it's a big trivia question we always
like to sprinkle in a quick trivia
question at this point so did you have
to die I didn't know I'm good Willem
Dafoe we walk can we pass out the
question the papers and the pens so Erik
Bosse r.i.p he recently re-watched it
we've got a really cool breakdown coming
and super late cuz he's super distracted
but he's been identifying all sorts of
cool trivia and the question that he's
left for all of us is in the movie it
what a spooky tongue-twister phrase does
Bill keep repeating to work on his
stutter I've never seen it well users
you are the mother of dragons I believe
in you so while we all come up with our
answers of what the spooky tongue
twister from the movie it is let's
listen to a sneak peek at that breakdown
that eric has coming meanwhile inside
the library I loved this creepy detail
when Ben flips through the town's
history an old woman in the background
stairs directly at him smiling and each
time the camera cuts back to this angle
she appears one step closer then when
Ben turns around to follow the balloon
downstairs this woman is back looking at
the stacks like normal this woman is
another incarnation of it appearing to
Ben at the precise moment he begins to
feel afraid
all right we're collecting our answers
and it's always the person with the best
slash closest answer as decided by our
judge as we could seven they get to do
our sign offs they say what our names
handles our and the loser is gonna have
to suck on something whoa stay tuned to
figure out what that thing is it's a
win-win I did not tell anyone what the
no you the loser doesn't get anyway
in other news moving on we're gonna get
you guys cut up on everything else
that's important that you need to know
about this week so I'm gonna run through
the news there anyone feel free to chime
in if you have anything but these are
things you have to know if anyone's
gonna quiz you at a nerd party
first up we got a new behind-the-scenes
featurette for Star Wars Episode eight
the last Jedi it's mostly interviews
from director Brian Johnson and various
cast members boy there are two slightly
miscible details in there one is that we
see Benicio Del Toro's character DJ uh
who I initially when I read that I
thought it was a DJ DJ disc jockey alien
reference anyway
he appears behind Finn and he's dressed
in a first-order uniform so I think
we're getting another secret
infiltration plot yeah yeah exactly
see I love those things because I still
think of them as using like rebel
tactics and like you have to infiltrate
I don't go like hooked on the Mara Jade
thing what about well starts off evil
but then they turn good so you think
that's what's going on so that's what
happens that's true yeah we've seen DJ
in a different look but it's you're
right if this is earlier the movie then
I'm surprised that no one has facial
recognition cameras in this you can
teleport billions of miles that you
still use pulleys and levers on their
show baby moving on there's another one
and it's another shot as a giant
adorable space horses known as father's
yeah better because the reference they
people just ride them and on canto
bright fight but yeah they're so cute
and I think
like neverending story yeah it's Falkor
right there's a better shot from from
the d23 footage but yeah cute horse a
lot of cute animals I'm still saying
that the pork is a snack for Chewbacca
also another news last Sunday was a
season 8 premiere of The Walking Dead
drawing the lowest number of viewers for
season 3 of the show since season 4 of
Roseanne it still had 11.5 million
viewers that's a 40 percent drop in its
key demographics and 11 no no here's the
thing I got it I got an email about it
from AMC today that said by the way
we're still the top show every year the
amount of content in ways you can view
splinters by like 50 percent so like
from season to season there's now 19
different ways to watch Walking Dead you
couldn't do last year you can do on your
phone yeah but I also think just as my
personal opinion year I think that
there's not as much charge going into
the show right now is there used to be
but Eric is still gonna get into what
did happen that season premiere in the
break down so check that out unless I
replace Eric forever all right
so other news this week yeah Deathstroke
is getting his own movie hey ma do you
know Joe Manganiello yeah Joe
marshmallow you tell the story but then
I'll give you the inside okay cool great
so he was attached obviously to the
Batman and then all that chaos happened
with a flex version of the Batman and
one of the big questions was what's
gonna happen with the Deathstroke story
and most recently we'd heard while
they're throwing the whole script out so
does that even mean they keep the same
villain now they're saying well
districts gonna get a movie that's gonna
be directed by Gareth Evans who directed
the freakin raid
and we know this character is perfectly
set up for that mod what's the deeper
dive so yeah they basically came to Joe
Manganiello and they're like we know
that you're a huge fan you love do you
see you love this character a lot
probably not going to see it in Batman
anytime soon so picture us a movie so he
along with a couple of others
brainstormed an entire script and wrote
up like a plot in the plan for the
character of Deathstroke and then I did
a bunch of test shoots which have
already been leaked out and yeah the
chances are that he's going to have his
own standalone movie but this is
something that he's been championing
that the studio nearly walked away from
and he was like no I want to be
destroyed
and I'll tell you why the world needs
Deathstroke and why this is important so
he basically championed to have this
character is in my Dungeons & Dragons
group every Sunday night he seems like a
great hugger gosh what do you first book
do knows like hell hello
and he's just so wide and so tall and
Abbott but Gareth if I may say really
quick he has on the you can go to
Netflix right now if you're in America
VHS to a multiple directors should make
little horror shorts for those Gareth
Evans did one and it's absolutely
amazing it's about a cult recommend it
that boy right there I'm very excited
this is he the way he directs action is
mind-blowing so yeah awesome I mean the
rate is worth watching just for actually
not really the coolest Sam Carly if Sam
Charlie went through a rebellious period
[Laughter]
bazinga man you're about to get Magnum
is not something anyone should say
boat sounds in other news the venom
movie began production this week the
movies Twitter account tweeted this
ohso detail packed behind the scenes
photo caption day 1 careful there are so
many spoilers here I'm being terribly
what is that be cooking up a storm yeah
you could do Tom Hardy on the right
there he's obviously playing venom or
Eddie Brock riza meds in this Michelle
Williams is in is Reid Scott it's gonna
be rated R and it's gonna fear feature
venom against carnage which is a pretty
interesting story actually pretty decent
way but my real question is no he's the
secret you can't see what he is the
ghost Fanta maybe that's carnage I'm
excited for the movie it's gonna be
weird and it's the director from zombie
lands decided to see a spider-man maybe
not mean like not with spider-man like
you're in the universe and so we're
having characters that we know and love
but in such a new setting I think this
could be the Dark Knight version of
spider-man or is it just because we're
good i recurrent like Tom Hardy he put
Tom Hardy we also learned this week from
Logan director James Mangold he's doing
a Logan spin-off following x-23 he said
that the success of Wonder Woman
actually made it so that there's less of
a fear of having a female protagonist
which is amazing so risks and they're
also open to exploring a new genre
that's appropriate for x-23 because
obviously Logan was a Western and you
could involve all the kids that they had
and they're like Richter he'll I can get
my control the ground everything it was
super violent so I kind of hope they
stick with that if they were to do an X
23 movie cuz it but also have the kids
also ask you think that the main actress
who played I think is Daphne Keane the
answer name I could be wrong though but
whoever played X 23 and Logan do you
would you guys want her and she was yeah
I want to get the better the x-men movie
that we always wanted suppose you've
already ruined one
child's life by exposing them to that
kind of violence so like they might as
well just keep her on that course or
they like put another child in those
shoes a serial killer
yeah good job Fox I'm excited and then
we also got some news on daredevil
season 3 on Netflix of Vincent D'Onofrio
is coming back as kingpin again baby man
one of I'm saying kilgrave is the best I
can't stand Vincent D'Onofrio did you
watch season 2 alright because I
couldn't go it's Pam versus Punisher
it's pretty okay his arc is just a
little because I noticed that he talks
he would just like try to do so many
things in the morning sentence it's like
come on what is the word you're trying
to say he's frightened to get the words
out he's fighting to get the words out
it's a consistent breakfast every
morning and for that alone I admire just
pointing out so the showrunner now is
gonna be different is gonna be the guy
who does the man in the high castle also
worked on arrow and then I wasn't gonna
mention that one cuz he worked on arrow
season 3 when it started to not get so
it makes sense because he did the third
season of that now he's doing the third
season at this those things in three or
six or nine know do you know the mama
dude or a sequence or 2124 all right you
guys are show off speaking of numbers
it's time for the by the numbers
so we're all caught up on everything
else this one's just a little bit of
research that's been doing around this
time of year because obviously you know
you freak out when you have a Halloween
coming and you're like what am I gonna
wear but what am I going to wear that is
easy and hot right now
or if you're like me what am I gonna
wear that everyone like but isn't what
everyone else is gonna wear so we're
gonna tell you the top most googled
costumes that are out for 2017 Wow
can you guess though yes well last year
we remember it was Holly Queen yeah it's
like bad Wonder Woman definitely and the
third was a big one was Dwayne Johnson
from Baywatch that's Wayne Johnson yeah
I'll throw out Dustin from stranger
things anybody else have any out there
guesses Willem Dafoe from anyone it's
gonna be penny wise by a landslide
Wonder Woman's gonna be first for sure I
think Harley Quinn's still on there I
think I think we're probably still let's
reveal it sexy cat is four boom Wonder
Woman topping it out 48% Wow people
looking for costumes are looking for
Wonder Woman costume yeah 12 or Center
want to be a Harley Quinn and 10% want
to be a different clown we think it but
it's hard when it is just a pronoun
because it could also refer to the Joker
Harley Quinn's there than the joy
because there's a good but I won't know
what this other kitten yeah
all people are in a room there would
only be one that isn't on the list yeah
it's a one of those so let's talk a
little bit what we all actually plan to
be on actual Halloween I don't know if
these are exact costumes this is just
something I just happen to come in today
and uh-huh but how are you guys gonna do
one of those four I mean I kind of
considered Wonder Woman I was pretty
cool
that would've been a penny wise would
also be pretty fun like having fun with
the makeup new penny wise are all penny
wise new penny wise I don't find the old
one that's scary the new one is pretty
terror I'm not yeah that's scary
no I just I'm not a clown person anymore
never had a problem
you were once a clown I'm going to be
someone I've been personated so much
that I figured I should finally dedicate
an entire night in costume to Laura Dern
from Jurassic Park just run
is she dragging him flashlights behind
it's wrapped around it ah that's why
yeah I like that as a reference your
thing has you running away from her
conversation well right now I am this
this is it this is this we're not gonna
see him for three weeks
oh you're not knowing I'm actually doing
with a friend we we have the same
costume no we're a Willem Dafoe's
character that we just learned this for
fall Oh Klaus Dom yeah Dom yeah whatever
from Life Aquatic with Steve Zissou and
the only thing missing from my costume
is I have a Steve Zissou patch zoo no
it's in the street in the movie so Steve
Zissou Wes Celia here oh let's just
agree to Tommy of what other well my
religion is celebrating Halloween so
okay so these days around Halloween I
think I'm gonna be John Candy's
character from national influence
vacation the security guard at Walley
world
I like that one I might also be Hodor
just gonna have that one so you were
asleep in 1988 and you woke up in 2050
yeah I'd like to know that I'm
definitely a hold yeah so I'll be taking
my 19 year old son out and you know
maybe I just won't dress up maybe I'll
just be myself the brave this costume is
your own skin so as we mentioned earlier
there's been off for Logan coming
following x-23 of Laura Kinney it's in
the works
but there are also a bunch of other
extra properties because Fox is trying
to milk the x-men universe now that's
doing okay there's a Dark Phoenix movie
coming there's also new mutants who see
the trailer for Deadpool - we're just
gonna have cable in it and then there's
also a second season of Legion yes and
then there's still that poor poor gambit
Solo Channing Tatum left it there doing
it but what I want for you guys to each
pitch mean is your ideal x-men spin-off
movie and I'm gonna speak a little
slowly so that you guys have time to
think it's got a feature of mutant who
has not yet had a solo film and we
wouldn't need to know what their story
is who the villain would be and if you
can
who would star in it - the guy who only
really has a mouth for a face go ahead
and pitch me I just fruit like the
nineties cartoons that I love so much I
loved rogue and gambit in those and then
when I saw the first x-men movies it
came out the rogue was nothing like I
knew her and I felt almost betrayed so I
want to see road so damn twang wasn't
there oh she was so sassy she was so fun
and like she just was epic and I think
it got yeah totally sidetracked with
Anna Paquin's kind of girl-next-door
vibe she's not a girl next door she's
never been a girl next door she's been a
kick-ass girl
so I want to see road done right which
could then swallow the gambit solo movie
and then they could be paired up go
together so it'll be really cool if you
had like a gambit rogue love story and
men have some sort of like evil version
I mean the only thing we've ever I've
ever really seen in the movies is that
weird dysfunctional relationship between
Magneto and mistake but having like
another kind of couple thing going where
they have the amazing powers just one
you want to use it for helping a mum
when you're hurting that's usually the
basis of good and evil but see that kind
of going up against Josh Boone I'm
watching a lot of CW I realized I like
that idea I I don't mean this in a
negative way I wonder it almost feels
like a there's like a Twilight kind of
thing there miss that song I would be
happy to hear people yeah help me thank
us a really good road oh that's rough
southern girl well I don't actually care
that she actually be southern right now
this is because of how rug looked when I
fell in love with her I'm thinking the
entire cast of glow what about Adrianne
Palicki I know she's in shield though
she can no no she's not anymore now
she's over at Orval yeah she she had her
own show and that she did now yes they
can she's got that laughter I'd actually
like to see here kind of succeed more I
would like I could do a little younger
is what I would want out of it just
because I don't see rogue as like a
mature woman it kind of is especially
when she defines herself five
relationships a bit
I got one I got one Tommy
yeah pitch me okay first of all thank
you so much for having me here oh boy
I'm getting such a joke no so my idea as
it forms in my head two characters that
have already been seen in x-men films
but would be recast and reimagined it
would be a kind of a true detective
meets the Marvel Universe crime thriller
between Bobby Drake Iceman who has to go
and solve the murder of his friend who
has turned against him pyro State John
LD say around a severed a sensation yeah
so he begin movie opens with a pyro has
been murdered and Bobby Drake cannot use
the X problem solve this murder because
they won't support him because you know
he's in the Brotherhood and he's not a
good guy so he used to go rogue and no
pun intended and solve this murder in
along that lines assuming the gambit
doesn't go we have maybe it could be
somewhere in the swamp it could be they
take place in the south and gamba could
maybe come in as a side character a
cameo character maybe Italian character
and I don't know about a villain yet but
I would think like you know maybe like
an authentically evil Sabretooth not a
pro wrestler not Liev Schreiber being so
charming that you can't get mad at him
like a real good bad guy being super to
verrines Bravo
right because they were just murderous
people in the comics like with zero
remorse
so like this would be and he might be a
red herring like murderer of pyro but he
would at least be a nemesis throughout
the film like getting away maybe he's
also trying to solve the case maybe he
actually cares about pyro and it leads
them together to face a bigger evil
which of course would be the blob just
we don't know what happened to on
Westworld because he's like the stouter
he's the most stout of them than
Hemsworth's know that characters the
first was openly and accepted gay
character if I'm not mistaken in the
short universe could that be well I
think I would add it definitely an even
richer layer it's a friendship or just
something from lovers I see hi I just
remember the Jean Grey is out soon
because she's a psychic in the college I
used to try and prove I was psychic I
would just go around and say that to
people and it was horribly offensive no
one liked it I would just go like oh my
god you're gay how did you know that I
was asked to leave school several times
anyway so that's my pitch I guess I'm
asking for $50,000 for 33% people there
you go alright so in I think to get
people in seats maybe use a character
that they already know like Nightcrawler
or Kitty Pryde I think they'd so pretty
welcome also keeprite is like it rogue
is one of the premier like female x-men
also storm I don't know what story you
do with storms personally roaring a
little if she's interesting when you
like when like she interacts with Black
Panther that's really fun or like some
of the other Avengers but I personally
don't know any good storm stories
anyways
Nightcrawler could be really interesting
to get into his roots when he's he was
being like people were being like racist
or I mean they try to torture him and he
was in a covenant for a long time and it
was it's a messed up origin story could
be really interesting people like darker
stories
Kitty Pryde you could have like a
coming-of-age story because people love
that in spider-man get your x-men
version of that with Kitty Pryde before
she goes off to Xavier school for the
gifted youngsters but personally I think
you should do phantom X and phantom X is
a character that has like three brains
in his body and he can cast illusions
but he does heists a heist movie could
be really interesting because he teams
up with x-men all the time so you could
throw in Nightcrawler into that movie
and it could be a team of between
phantom X and Nightcrawler and Kitty
Pryde exactly you can do like exactly
I think font MX would be the coolest one
also as soon as that costume comes out
you'd be like that's like I want to be
him Bravo yeah he was brains behind the
operation he wears like a white suit a
great suit you got a mask everything he
uses a gun he's like kind of like James
Bond but he's got powers and he could
team up with other x-men and you could
see a couple other fun villains and
there as well bank heist movies where
you actually want them to get away with
it yeah cuz you get so much of a
backstory you realize why they're doing
it they're not actually bad that could
be cool in Fantomex is French so you get
an X in there Wow
you know what they actually want rogue
to be southern you get those all right
pitch me I'll say it real quick I'm not
gonna do a full one I'm just gonna say I
think it'd be cool if they took kind of
it doesn't have to be the exact Scarlet
Witch version of the storyline but
essentially a psychic is threatening all
other mutants and the all the psychics
have to like fight each other it's
specific a psychic storylines like all
right and then up next we have these are
questions from you guys that none of us
have seen actually we call it the
lightning round so these are literally
I'm pulling them up right now for the
first time so let's see what people want
to know so get ready to catch these okay
I don't know what that one means Sam yes
what's an indie comic that would make a
great movie or show franchise it's all
good
easy-peasy yeah the person set or saga
wink-wink
so yeah saga is a right answer on that
Rita ketchup my psycho psycho it would
be a great show
yeah it would be I think like an HBO you
have the money for that yeah in giant
dayz mod' out of everyone that shows up
on new rock stars on camera including
Thomas everyone who would most who'd be
most likely survived the longest in the
game of thrones universe oh why do you
it doesn't stop oh I would just hide
it's going okay people I've killed
someone Maude Wyatt goes out to just the
cops director tell me what good movies
don't get enough praise as much as they
should
oh man Rudy for one came out after 2010
okay
I really oh shoot man this hurts
I liked kick-ass the first kick-ass I
feel like that movie was considered a
bomb even though they made a sequel I
really liked it
let's see what else I like that movie
fury that tank movie with Brad Pitt like
I ever hated there like it was so slow
it's like yeah that was the point it
would be like suspenseful and I really
loved Dunkirk I don't know I've made me
hold my breath for like 87 minutes and I
liked that it was short like there was
no need for it to be as a Christopher
Nolan movie but it was like how he would
do a short who should play cable Josh
Brolin's doing it right now Ron Perlman
100% always Ron Perlman does poke out
his eye be great
what's a most scared you've ever been
from a TV show movie oh my god are you
kidding me I'm the most scared I'd be
yeah everyone got pretty freaking scared
which one got me the worst yeah I tried
to watch Candyman when I was 15
[Music]
[Laughter]
I didn't like this from UK custard
creams or jammie Dodger cut me off
earlier everybody knows peanut butter
cups go just kidding jammie toddlers are
my favorite you're a mustache man who
just said dammy toddlers are his
favorite that's Tommy Beck told you can
reach him never again you can reach me
know where we gotta do our first-ever
costume contest winners yes how are you
new rock stars how's Eric trash I'm so
excited to reveal these to you guys we
got a lot of entries but the judges and
gods have spoken and
these are our top three that for one
reason or another really stood out so if
you guys are one of these three and you
one make sure to tweet at us at new rock
stars and let us know hey that's me that
you're featuring in my sweet costume and
we'll give you your sweet cash money
toward Fandango so you can go see at the
amazing movies that are coming over the
next few months but seriously as you
guys can tell I take costumes way too
seriously and so I'm really impressed
with what you guys have done I thank you
guys so much these are amazing let's
give it up for them so up next we're
just gonna talk about real quick what we
have in the pipeline these are the
videos that are gonna be coming out next
week on new rock stars we've got
stranger things full season breakdown we
are benching as fast as we can to get
everything we can so you have an it
breakdown that's a little late yeah 30
things we think people missed and
watching it the first one or 10 times
our Walking Dead episode 2 for the
season breakdown thor ragnarok
post-credit scene or explain what's
going on there we have a Thor Ragnarok
breakdown coming out more Thor Ragnarok
stuff coming we know a lot about it and
we will know a lot about anyway you will
know a lot about it too if you've
watched those videos that come out I'll
flash Sam's yeah episode 4 very excited
by that make sure you tune in check out
all the other breakdowns like yeah I
catch up on those and then another need
to know and then we're gonna be at
Tommy's bail here okay also there's
gonna be a 40-minute tearful apology
from me for all of my comments on the
show
so that'll be really it'll be the three
things you missed that our criminal
admissions by me I don't know if you
know timely this is so people all right
so it's time for our trivia answer
normally we do our trivia answer let's
say I'm doing is cheating normally our
trivia answer comes a little later in
the show but there's a very specific
punishment
appropriately a slightly nothing sprayer
later they're back there okay so the
trivia question that we asked earlier
can you hand that cushion over yeah and
then can you pass the answers out to
someone who is not the person that wrote
it Oh
anyone who did not write that one give
it to them the question again was in the
movie it what spooky tongue-twister
phrase does bill repeat to work on his
stutter so the correct answer is he
thrusts his fists against the post and
still insists he sees the ghost Tommy
what did and his was I am NOT a fig
Tucker the Tucker of things person is it
me I will tuck figs until time to tuck
in and the fig they come from why I feel
like I'm being set up
big talker the techiniques person isn't
me I will tuck things until time to tuck
in and the fig Tucker arrives
I have mods Sally sells seashells by the
seashore
Sampson loose lips sink ships
[Music]
Yuri Erik Bosse eats electric eels at 11
o'clock not not too hairy
yeah seven who was the closest mod where
hers mods is the closest we got a pause
well we get the thing I got to suck on
[Music]
now it's time for the 15-second shout
out section alright say each of us has
15 seconds to rant and rave about the
one thing that everything we want
everyone to know about but we're gonna
do a special Halloween edition so it's
15 seconds about a movie or scary thing
that people can do this weekend a scary
movie people can watch this weekend go
check out train to Busan on Netflix also
if you're in the LA area go to Knott's
Scary Farm they've amaz'd called tooth
fairy and it's about kids getting
kidnapped and have their teeth ripped
out you go cuz you just sucked
[Music]
oh dear I want to give a shout out to
all the people that hate Halloween and
horror and a scared of everything like
me so just build a fort and sit under it
and don't watch any horror movies and
just to be really spiteful maybe every
time some kid comes to your door and
says trick-or-treat
say Trick ya like risk leave a little
just say trick hide under your fort and
then antagonize the local children
that's how you be more right that
something terrible will happen to you so
it is scary that's great Tommy what do
you got okay so if you're if you're
brave unlike me you know watch the Evil
Dead that's a super scary movie if
you're a chicken like me little monsters
is on Netflix so check out little
monsters should be just kind of scared
even as an adult
which version of Evil Dead the original
og Evil Dead one where the girl goes
we're gonna get you back as a little boy
you really scared me anyway have fun
everybody great and now to say it
follows guys if you haven't seen it
balls you have to see it here's a
Stardust uh for me talking about why it
follows is so damn good
make sure you see it follows even if
you've seen it before watch it again it
is just so good it encapsulates so many
other horror movies inside of it
John Carpenter's Halloween is
omnipresent throughout the whole thing
the original it is referenced a lot and
on top of that it packs in so many
themes and interesting images that are
relevant to teens like eating disorders
and pill dependencies and cutting
yourself and sexually transmitted
diseases are obviously a huge part of it
but it's amazing it's so good go watch
yeah I like that I said you should watch
it because it talks about STDs yeah what
a great detail alright so uh who won you
wanna you want to let everyone know what
they need to know yes hi my name is
Maude Garrett Mau de GA r ett that's all
you need to know because these fools
that got a go that's all that's all I'm
doing that's what happens when I win
that was thank you I mean even took the
odds that I get Maude Garrett go to
subscribe to geek bum Wow hey my son my
boy struck real quick remind everybody
to get on Stardust using that download
link in the description below posts your
reactions to film stuff tag us in them
at new rock stars and we will feature
them and next weeks need to know like
you saw on this episode actually and
next week we're gonna do a big Thor
episode well I've seen awesome so we'd
love to see your reactions or your even
more specific your questions about the
movie that you have questions for us
just send them to us all via Stardust
comment down below tweet us I had new
rock stars using hashtag need to know
like this video share it around so that
people watch this show it subscribed to
new rock stars for more deep dives
big thanks to all our host mod do you
not want any with surnames seriously you
can I had my moment and I feel really
good about it say I'm gonna hand the
baton back yeah got you Sam
have Sam basher go listen my podcast
only stupid answers ok Tommy we're gonna
find you in jail
that's ami Beck told Tommy Bechtel be
healthy how sometimes the mod again what
Garrett at what Garrett at Maude Garrett
where there's some geek bomb awesome I'm
Philip took me up at on Twitter
otherwise you'll see me here next time
and we'll see you next week bye bye
take care of everybody
bye guys change it off I made a wish on
that genie
alright yeah yeah yeah I'm keeping this
mirror